it's said the first time you take heroin
is the most euphoric High you will
experience it's a craving that users
Chase for the rest of their lives this
is something heroin addicts refer to as
chasing the dragon however Euphoria is
not the only reason a user continues to
take heroin as much as an addict May
return to heroin for the high there's
others who seek it for Refuge from the
agonizing throws of withdrawal in this
video I'll be discussing the dark
science behind heroin withdrawal
foreign
[Music]
withdrawal is characterized as an
intense period of sickness pains and
Cravings due to changes in body
chemistry from heroin altering neuron
activity
heroin belongs to the drug class called
opioids since it like other opiates bind
to opioid receptors to produce their
effects one opiate receptor in
particular that plays a major role in
changing body chemistry is the new
receptor mu receptors are found on
neurons in the essential nervous system
in the brain and spinal cord when heroin
binds to Mu receptors it causes a
prolonged release of dopamine which
produces a euphoric high in addition to
dopamine increase other changes in
neurotransmitters occur such as decrease
in acetylcholine an increase in
serotonin adding to the effects of
heroin one region in the brain that is
directly affected by heroin and changes
body chemistry is the locus cyrillius
one of the roles of the locus Aurelius
is making the hormone and
neurotransmitter norepinephrine
norepinephrine is a stimulant used to
heighten alertness by increasing heart
rate blood pressure and breathing taking
heroin disrupts the process of
norepinephrine production specifically
when heroin binds to Mu receptors in the
locus cyrillius a g protein is released
that inhibits an enzyme called The
Dental cyclase adenyl cyclase Converse
ATP into cyclic adenosine monophosphate
or C amp a messenger molecule when cm is
made it signals the production of
norepinephrine as C amp increases so
does norepinephrine and vice versa when
adenylocyclase is inhibited by the G
protein no cm is made and therefore
norepinephrine production drops because
norepinephrine is a stimulant When
there's less of it body functions become
depressed thus slower norepinephrine
contributes to the aesthetic effects of
heroin such as lower blood pressure
muscle weakness and slowed breathing
however the body cannot be without
norepinephrine as it needs it to
function to counteract a dental cyclase
being inhibited the body responds by
producing more of it as more heroin is
taken more adenyl cyclase needs to be
made to make norepinephrine consequently
this increase in a dental cyclase is a
major cause of withdrawal effects
withdrawal begins after the user has
been off heroin for about 8 to 12 hours
the initial symptoms are fairly mild
with anxiety and Cravings due to lack of
dopamine being released however after 24
hours symptoms quickly become severe
this is due to the increase of
adenocyclase enzymes which are no longer
inhibited by heroin The increased number
of enzymes create a large amount of C
amp which signals a proportionally large
production of epinephrine as a result
the body is flooded with norepinephrine
the large release of norepinephrine
overstimulates bodily functions causing
an increase in alertness heart rate
breathing and perspiration these
heightened stimulant defects are what
cause to withdraw symptoms of insomnia
muscle cramps vomiting hot and cold
flushes and anxiety
in fact withdrawal symptoms are the
exact opposite of the high effects right
down to the neurotransmitters being
released under the influence of heroin
norepinephrine and acetylcholine are
decreased whereas dopamine and serotonin
are increased by contrast during
withdrawal norepinephrine and
acetylcholine increase and dopamine and
serotonin decrease
after 48 Hours another symptom is added
to the list excessive diarrhea this is
because heroin being a sedative slows
down digestion and the movement of stool
in the intestines sometimes to the point
of constipation then during withdrawal
the body releases large amounts of
norepinephrine in acetylcholine both of
which speeds up motility of stool in the
colon this causes immediate liberation
of constipated stool resulting in
diarrhea by day 3 of withdrawal users
experience Peak intensity of Cravings
the body creates more dopamine receptors
to accommodate increased dopamine being
released from heroin interference with
high receptor count the body is used to
receiving a surge of dopamine on a
consistent basis during withdrawal
however there is less dopamine being
released the body responds to this by
increasing Cravings to cause the
individual to seek out High releasing
dopamine activities such as taking
heroin by day 5 the severe withdrawal
symptoms begin to subside the body
begins to reduce the number of
adenocyclitis enzymes in dopamine
receptors insomnia muscle pains and
anxiety also drop to subclinical levels
it's the first two to four days of
withdrawal that make quitting heroin so
incredibly difficult the desire to
escape from pain and suffering is enough
to send any user back into relapse this
is why going off heroin cold turkey is
not recommended in order to lessen
withdrawal symptoms the user is often
given a long-acting and less addictive
opiate common ones you may have heard
are methadone buprenorphine and
Naltrexone these opiates are less potent
than heroin so they release less
dopamine and don't inhibit adenocyclase
as severely this allows the body to
gradually adjust to lower dopamine and
higher norepinephrine levels finally by
day 30 withdrawal symptoms are
completely gone and body chemistry has
returned back to normal though the
physical urge to take heroin is gone the
user retains a mental Association of the
drug from here addiction therapy and
change of lifestyle is needed to prevent
relapse
sometimes science can be seen as
difficult foreign and even boring yet
there are times when science grabs our
attention and draws Us in yearning for
more answers often what draws a center
topics that are dark Macabre or
terrifying it's with the intention of
this video that you too were drawn in
and sought to have your questions
answered thanks for watching Dark
science
[Music]